peptic ulcers are painful sores in the
lining of our stomach or the first part
of the small intestine but the 1970s the
medical community had widely accepted
the theory that excess stomach acid was
a root cause of peptic ulcer disease
this famous no acid no alsa Dogma was
based on decades of rigorous scientific
study and supported by sound
experimental evidence that acid rooting
drugs cured the painful symptoms of
ulcers in this video we'll see how the
subsequent discovery of a gastric
bacterium he liquor back to pylori or h
pylori for short transformed our
understanding of peptic ulcer disease
the two Australian physicians who
elucidated h pylori role in ulcer
disease Barry Marshall and Robin Warren
will awarded the 2005 nobel prize in
medicine for their groundbreaking
discovery this video is part of the
problem solving video series problem
solving skills in combination with an
understanding of the natural and
human-made world are critical to the
design and optimization of systems and
processes hi my name is adrian lee and
i'm an emeritus professor of medical
microbiology at the University of New
South Wales in Sydney Australia I've
worked on spiral shaped bacteria in the
intestines since nineteen sixty eight
and so worked in parallel with Marshall
and Warren over the course of their
discovery one of the greatest moments of
my life was when they invited me and my
wife to the Nobel Prize award ceremony
in Stockholm Sweden thus I know their
story very well and consider it to be a
wonderful summary of science in action
before watching this video you should be
familiar with the scientific method and
its central role in the investigation of
scientific phenomenon by the end of this
video you will be able to one describe
the general steps the scientific method
to recognize the complex and
multifaceted nature of the scientific
process and three explain how the
discovery h.pylori and its connection to
peptic ulcer disease exemplifies key
aspects of the scientific process
before going to war on Marshalls story I
first have a question for you what do
you think of some of the steps involved
in the process of scientific
investigation
some you might have said conduct
experiments make observations analyze
data disseminate results or something
similar these are all key elements of
the scientific method the scientific
method provides us with an objective and
systematic way to focus our inquiry and
organize our curiosity as shown here the
scientific method is often presented
linearly but really the scientific
method is highly iterative and nonlinear
most scientists do not follow a rigid
checklist there isn't one standard way
to do science science is a dynamic
process not effects methodology
let's return to Marshall and Warren and
the events that led to their Nobel
prize-winning discovery see if you can
identify that there is elements of the
scientific method our story begins with
Rama Warren a history of ethology at the
Royal Perth Hospital in Western
Australia in 1979 Warren noticed a thin
dark line in specimens from his gastric
biopsy patients he switched the
microscope to a higher magnification and
observe what looked like spiral shaped
bacteria he notices a bacteria almost
always associated with evidence of
gastritis or inflammation of the stomach
Warren was convinced that the bacteria
were important but the time doctors
believe that no bacteria could survive
in the acid stomach and thus showed
little interest in his work two years
later Barry Marshall then a young
clinical trainee in the same hospital
join Warren in his study of gastric
bacteria Warren convinced Marshall that
the spiral bacteria was significant and
not just contamination from the
laboratory to further study the bacteria
they would first need to grow up
cultures in the lab this proved to be
frustratingly difficult Marshall tried
culturing spar bacteria from 30
different patients the result was always
the same blank petri dishes then in
april nineteen eighty-two Warriner
Marshall left for the Easter holiday and
when they returned from the five day
break they were surprised to find
thriving bacterial growth the problem
hadn't been the culture process the
bacteria is simply slow growers and
after more than a year Marshall morin
finally had their bacteria
microbiologist at the Royal Perth
Hospital started identification tests
and found the bacterium to be of a
completely new Janice it was eventually
named helicobacter pylori or h pylori as
they were trying to grow the bacterium
in the lab Marshall more'n were also
trying to determine the medical role of
their bacterium they examine gastric
samples from a hundred patients where to
their surprise h pylori found in more
than half
specimens the bacterium was almost
always present in patients with
gastritis and peptic ulcers so Warren
Marshall began to suspect that gastric
diseases were in fact caused by h pylori
and eagerly presented their findings to
the medical community much of the
disappointment their bacterial theory
was widely rejected and ridiculed it was
an uphill battle trying to publish their
results in medical journals instead of
backing down Marshall and Warren sought
other opportunities to spread the word
they presented their results at the
European campylobacter meeting in
Brussels in September 1983 I was in the
audience that day and can still recall
the excitement of hearing about this new
bacterium at around the same time in
English microbiologist Martin's giro
successfully cultured h pylori from
biopsy specimens in his own laboratory
he convinced the influential medical
journal the lancet to publish Warren and
Marshalls definitive paper in 1984 again
their radical hypothesis was harshly
condemned some criticized their lack of
experimental controls others dismiss our
idea is offensive to move forward Roran
and marshall would need more
experimental proof that h pylori cause
gastritis and peptic ulcer disease the
usual way to prove a bacterium causes a
particular disease is to use an animal
model in other words find an animal that
is also susceptible to the disease and
early on animal models for h pylori were
hard to find frustrated and not being
taken seriously and hindered by this
lack of an animal model Barry Marshall
came up with a dramatic way to prove
this point he drank a culture of h
pylori Marshall became ill with nausea
and vomiting within a week endoscopy
confirmed the presence of gastritis and
h pylori and more importantly the
symptoms disappeared after antibiotic
treatment Marshall now had some evidence
linking h pylori infection of a normal
stomach
gastric information still this did
little to convince the skeptics in
science a large sample size is important
to achieve statistically significant
results this experiment with just one
subject was clearly not good science
however it certainly captured the
attention of the media and the word of
the guinea pig doctor who discovered a
new cure for ulcers started to spread
Marshall and warren's find engaged
significant support among members of the
microbiology community who were immune
to the no acid no alsa dogma of the
medical profession several
microbiologist including Martin Sierra
myself became intrigued by h pylori and
set out to understand it better well
after Marshall volunteered himself as a
test subject I on a colleague at MIT Jim
Fox successfully developed a mouse model
of infection using what we call the
Sydney strain of h pylori this and other
animal models provided a starting point
for further studies in h pylori and its
role in peptic ulcer disease in the
early 1990s evidence built up in support
of Marshall and Warren's hypothesis
clinical trials showed that antibiotics
not only cured the symptoms of altars
but also prevented their recurrence in
contrast acid reduces medication
alleviate adults of symptoms but not
their occurrence in 1994 15 years after
Warren's initial observation a panel
from the US National Institutes of
Health finally published a statement
stating that the key to the treatment of
peptic ulcers was detection and
eradication of h pylori it had taken
more than a decade of exhaustive
research by Warren Marshall and many
others for the bacterial theory of
ulcers to gain official acceptance
the impact of Marshall and Warren's work
was profound peptic ulcer disease is no
longer a chronic debilitating medical
condition we now know that many else's
of caused by bacteria and can be cured
of permanently with antibiotics at a
fraction of the cost of earlier
treatment methods can you identify steps
of the scientific method that Marshall
Morin used in their discovery
you might have noted Warren's initial
observation of h pylori in gastric
biopsy samples or his questioning of h
pylori is rolling gastritis marginal
morin hypothesized a bacterial cause of
gastric disease and subsequent
experiments demonstrate the
effectiveness as antibiotics in the
treatment of peptic ulcers finally they
disseminated their findings amongst a
medical and research community the
helicobacter story illustrates how good
science is at the heart of every
important scientific discovery however
science is only one part of the story
and as we've seen even good data can be
met with rejection so where personal
characteristics allowed Marshall and
Lauren to ultimately succeed despite
overwhelming skepticism and negativity
there are a few characteristics that i
believe were crucial to marshall a
success curiosity fundamental to the
process of discovery is the inside of
the individual investigator this story
as a results for Robin Lauren's keen
observation of a few spiral bacteria and
its desire to determine their origins
luck from Warren Marshalls initial
meeting to the long Easter weekend away
from the lab there is no question that
serendipity played a significant role in
their scientific journey tenacity Warren
Marshalls persistent was exemplified by
they dogged determination to tell others
about h pylori even in the face of
constant criticism with Marshall even
volunteering himself as a guinea pig by
turning to microbiologist another
scientist to address the questions
surrounding h pylori they eventually
gained acceptance in the medical
community
in this video you've heard the
fascinating story a Roma Warren and
Barry Marshall and how it took them more
than a decade of experimentation and the
right mix of curiosity luck and a
persistence to overturn the deeply
entrenched no acid no Elsa dogma of the
medical establishment as their guest at
the 2005 Nobel Prize award ceremony in
stockholm sweden i had the privilege of
seeing our two heroes receive the
ultimate reward in scientific research
the 2005 nobel prize in medicine for
their groundbreaking work on h pylori so
often science is taught as irrefutable
truth but this story reminds us that
scientific truth can and does change in
the face of new evidence moving forward
I hope that you will bear in mind the
various elements responsible for marshal
run success and apply them to your own
learning